democrats now fear school closings will
hurt them politically chicago public
school schools have been closed since
wednesday because 73 percent of
chicago's teachers union voted on
tuesday against returning to classroom
and only teaching remotely democrats are
fetting fretting that another school
year interrupted by foreclo by closures
distance learning and uncertainty could
hurt them in the future elections
because they have close ties to the
unions democrats are concerned that
additional closures like those in
chicago could lead to a possible replay
of the party's recent loss in virginia's
governor race this is a new york times
story reported polling shows that school
disruptions were an important issue for
swing voters who broke republican
particularly suburban white women boom
there's do you see that happening in the
midterms so you look at it let's look at
the junior issue it's rasmussen not
fauci is going to determine the election
and that's what we're worried about now
after after virginia my my wife saw this
uh this meme on social media and it said
the why ma the wine mom giveth and the
wine mom taketh away
right i love them that's phenomenal and
at the end of the day kenny are you
listening
you start messing with mama bear's kids
right and you start adding stress to her
husband because now they're trying to
figure out how to deal with child care
and when both like my wife works um i
work right i mean
we now we're lucky enough that our kids
are toddlers during this crazy time but
if our kids were in school lots of my
friends lots of my lots of my employees
this has caused a massive disruption in
their household which adds stress to the
household you start adding stress to mom
and bear's household and she's going to
come out swinging and and really the
only independent voters i'm not changing
your mind you're not changing my mind
but you know what
my wife can kind of look at some of the
more social issues and things like that
where i tend to i tend to vote on
economics um and i think that i think
that story plays out around the country
and so that's where i think you're gonna
you're gonna see the you start messing
with the schools you're messing with
mama bear and she thinks that her kids
aren't getting the education that they
need and she's going to come out
fighting because she won't fight for
herself all that well but she will die
on a hill first and we have a clear case
example which happened in virginia with
gene younkin and uh terry mcauliffe is a
critical race theory like i don't think
that's even a major issue but
maybe it's a major issue i'll tell you
how right you are i mean we sat down we
had an interview with rudy giuliani
which you guys can see at mafia states
of america but he made a very
interesting point
where
you can you can reduce the murder rates
20 30 and nobody believes you because
nobody ever sees a murder they think
you're juicing it but if you get rid of
the the squeegee guys and you get rid of
the graffiti the quality of life crimes
everybody sees things improving so it's
politics of
burden now because of their politics
it's a burden on my household now i'm
pissed off they made it a burden on me
it's very now they brought their
politics to my doorstep and i'm
resentful about that that's a very good
point the other thing is deeper and i've
heard people talk about this
i i tell you guys off air
they're they they need the schools to
reopen because that's where they know
they control the narrative when the kids
are at home and they're on the video
games and you see kyrie irving is
playing basketball because all of the
vaccinated guys
are
sick with kovid so they have to bring
kyrie the unvaccinated guy back to play
yeah there's not a teacher to sit there
and explain that away in the classroom
to these 30 kids and manipulate and
brainwash them now they're sitting
online playing call of duty with each
other going like oh governor these guys
are [ __ ] like you know so they need
the kids in school
because they need to control
how they're they need to influence them
essentially and the less that they're by
the way the less influence by the way
what you just said what you just said
is pretty wild
and does that mean the conservatives are
kind of uh playing a proxy saying hey
then slow your roll with these kids
going back to school is that kind of
what you're thinking is it they didn't
think that but now that you're saying
you know maybe we take one
game
you're giving the gop way too much
credit for any sort of foresight or
ability to seize on a moment oh my god
something it's really interesting is
this comes full circle over a 10-year
horizon with pat and i pat and i were um
in a a very wealthy california town down
the street from pepperdine university
and heard ed gillespie and terry
mcauliffe what a debate gave a debate
yeah to about 70 people with pat and i
in the back saying how did we get in
here um at the time but it was very very
cool and i thought terry mcauliffe was
very opinionated and too close to the
too close to the third rail right then
so it doesn't surprise me that he
basically says offhand and it wasn't a
flub it wasn't a gaff it's half what he
believed it was i'm your nanny that's
what he said and that's what he believes
and oh no i really didn't believe that
he lost on what he believed in and mama
bear came to the polls and showed him a
real power from the 12 in the middle
where all elections are fought now
it's only the 12 in the middle five for
green
40 over here 40 over here that's locked
it's the 12 in the middle and you just
discovered what the independent the
power of the independent voter really
looks like nick nick let it slip in in
the podcast a few weeks back man when he
said that no i believe in a global
federation and we're like you just
advocated for a new world yeah
matt zeller my bad sorry
guys my god
100 he was like yeah we should we we
should get away from the nation state
and we should have a global federation
agency who ran for who ran for congress
as a democrat he and he and i can have a
parking lot conversation but by the way
you know what you know what would be
interesting here's what would be
interesting
uh he he's a fighter he he he's a feisty
guy loves him some tulsi gabbard yeah
he's a he's
but with
with that i'm talking with jack barski
about bringing jack barskin on the
podcast jack barks is a former kgb guy i
know him and if we bring him on board
it'd be kind of interesting to bring the
cia because what he says is very weird
and i'd like to see somebody from the
cia hold him accountable something maybe
we're going to have debates like this on
this podcast
there's no such thing as an xkgb spy
spies
but jack and i
can come together on the human
trafficking issue and be like hey we
don't agree on a lot but we will
freaking we will go to war against this
issue so so you'd want to do a podcast
with jack and you on it uh
okay
so so maybe we'll coordinate that so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you